well the ace is open the postseason
tonight at mandalay bay they're playing
phoenix in the best of five series and
sports director chris matthews is
courtside for tonight's game joins us
with the preview chris
well thank you very much guys an
exciting night here in las vegas as the
ace has taken on the phoenix mercury the
aces have hit all their goals so far
reach the postseason they want to get
one of those top two seeds so they would
get that double buy into the semifinals
which they did and now they are what
bouncing what three wins away from
getting back into the wnba championship
by the way the aces have had seven
players average in double figure so it's
been a phenomenal year for this las
vegas franchise joining me now is the
president of the franchise nikki
ferguson nikki this really has been a
fun year you've been here since may so
you've kind of witnessed this season
unfold it's been a busy but a fun season
it has been uh you know when you look at
this team and what they've been able to
accomplish going on playing for our
country winning gold medals both in the
505 and the three on three and then
coming back and competing in one of the
toughest if you talk about women's
basketball in the world this is the
toughest league to play in and you can
see the talent every night the
competition is at the at the highest
level and we've got some of the best
players in the world playing right here
for the aces well as the president of
the las vegas aces it's easy for you
because you got great people to promote
like asia wilson kelsey plum and all
those players
how's it been going i know you get a lot
of
outsiders that come in and have fun
watching the aces well you know what's
so spectacular is that mark davis made
the point to say first off i'm going to
buy and purchase the aces team but the
second thing that he was really
committed to was the relationship and
the synergy amongst the raiders and the
aces so you're going to probably see
tonight half of the football team about
17 18 of the players will be here
tonight raider nation will be
representing
all right that is nikki fargus we are
out of time it's going to have so much
fun we are outside the mandalay bay
getting ready for the big game we are
live local now we'll see you at 6